ED COPELAND: I'm going to
introduce pi in a way that I
don't think many people
have seen before.
A friend of mine, David Tong,
told me about this.
And I think it's really neat.
And it involves rolling
balls at each other.
Our thought experiment involves
just two balls.
So there's a small ball, and
we'll give it a mass little m.
And there's a big ball.
And we'll give this mass a big
M. This is actually a 10-pin
bowling ball which I
believe you stole.
Now, the idea is that this ball,
the big ball, is rolling
with some initial velocity.
And it hits the little ball.
Now the little ball moves
off and hits the wall.
And it bounces elastically.
That means that when it bounces
it doesn't lose any
kinetic energy or
any momentum.
It bounces back.
Meanwhile, the big ball
is carrying on.
It hits the big ball.
And then, of course,
it bounces back.
The big ball--
it's imparted a little bit of
momentum to the big ball,
which is now slowing down.
It goes back, bounces again,
comes back, bounces back, goes
back, and just keeps
doing this.
Eventually, the big ball slows
down enough that it stops and
at the next collision will
begin to go back.
OK?
So the system is the ball's
coming in, there's a number of
collisions, and then the
big ball eventually
bounces and goes back.
What's that got to do with pi?
The question is how many
collisions between the big
ball and the little ball before
the big ball starts
going the other way.
OK?
It's as simple as that.
Now as long as the mass of
this big ball is quite
particular.
In fact, it's given as--
in terms of the little mass,
it's given as 16 times 100 to
the power N, where I'm going
to let this number N vary.
So if N is 0, the big ball is
16 times the mass of the
little ball.
If n is 1, the big ball is 1,600
times the mass of the
little ball.
If N is 2, the mass is 160,000
times that of the little ball.
So as long as you've got this
very particular mass, then it
turns out that the number of
collisions between the big
ball and the little ball
is the first N
plus 1 digits of pi.
So if N equals 0, then
the number of--
so the big ball is 16 times the
mass of the little ball,
there'll be three collisions.
If N is 1, so the big ball is
1,600 times that of the little
ball, and so there will
be 31 collisions.
If N is 3, there'll
be 314 collisions.
If N is 4, there'll be
3,141 collisions.
What's remarkable about
this, I think, is
that this is exact.
As long as N is an integer and
you let it get bigger and
bigger and bigger, you will
get exactly the relevant
number of digits of pi.
So if this was three grams,
and this is about 4.8
kilograms, then there would
be of order 31 collisions.
So if I scale this up, so this
was a boulder of mass 480
kilograms, then there should be
314 collisions before the
boulder begins to
go backwards.
BRADY HARAN: I guess these
things are round and have
circumferences and pi,
so is that where this
is all coming from?
ED COPELAND: It's got
nothing to do with
that, which is fantastic.
In fact, if this was a point
object, with very massive--
and that was a point
object, the same
thing would still apply.
The fact that it's round has
nothing to do with it.
What is important is that the
collision is elastic, that it
conserves energy and conserves
and momentum.
But it could be any shaped
object that would do that.
BRADY HARAN: So this has nothing
to do with circles.
ED COPELAND: This has nothing
at all to do with the circle
of this ball and the circle
of this ball.
BRADY HARAN: So if that was a
cube or something else--?
ED COPELAND: I think, yes,
that would still work.
As long as we're in the
collision, you've conserved
energy and momentum.
BRADY HARAN: Ahh, I think
you're going to have to
explain that.
ED COPELAND: OK.
Here we go.
Let's try and make sense of two
balls hitting each other
and how we get pi out of it.
Let's just draw it again.
And so the idea is I have some
surface and then I have some
wall at the end.
And I have a little ball of,
mass, little m, and I a big
ball of mass big M.
And initially, the big ball is
moving with some velocity.
Let's call it u.
And it hits the little ball.
And then what happens is the
little ball begins to go
towards the wall.
Meanwhile, the big
ball carries on.
The big ball is still moving.
The little ball hits the
wall and comes back.
And then it hits the
big ball again.
And so the little ball bounces
back, hits this
wall, bounces back.
I mean each time the little
ball hits the big ball, it
transfers a bit of its momentum
over to the big ball.
Then the big ball
will slow down.
And in fact, eventually, the
big ball will stop and will
begin to go the other way.
And what we want to know is if
that happens after, say, p
steps, then how does p--
the number of collisions--
depend upon the mass
of the big ball?
Now what's important here-- the
only bit that I've had to
throw in that I must say Brady
wasn't that impressed with
when I told him, but still
I think it's neat--
is that there's a very
particular value for the big
ball that we're interested in.
The mass of the big ball is 16
times 100 to the power N times
the mass of the little ball.
So if N equals 0, then the big
ball is just 16 times the mass
of the little ball.
If N equals 1, then the big ball
is 1,600 times the mass
of the little ball.
Then you get the idea.
If N equals 2, then the big ball
is 160,000 times the mass
of the little ball.
So rapidly--
BRADY HARAN: It jumps
up in hundreds.
ED COPELAND: It jumps
That's right.
BRADY HARAN: Not tens.
ED COPELAND: Not tens.
Now, in each case, you can ask
how many steps, how many
collisions of the big ball and
the little ball are there
before the big ball starts
going in the opposite
direction, in other words,
before the big ball starts
going backwards.
And the result is remarkable.
So the number of steps when
N equals 0 is equal to 3.
So the number of collisions
is 3.
The number of collisions
when N equals 1 is 31.
And the number of collisions
when N equals 2 is 314.
And it goes on.
It goes on so that for the
case of a general N, the
number of collisions is the
first N plus 1 digits of pi,
pi being 3.141 dot
dot dot dot.
And it's true for any N. So as
N goes towards infinity, you
just keep recovering the first
N plus 1 digits of pi.
It's not an expansion or
anything like that.
It's just the expression
that you get.
BRADY HARAN: And nothing
to do with circles.
ED COPELAND: Nothing
You can work out this, and the
key ingredients that you need,
which we do at school, is you
need to remember that we have
conservation of energy
in the collision and
conservation of momentum.
That's all we need
to make use of.
And when you've got that, you
can work out the velocity of
the part of the big ball
after N collisions.
It's possible to do that.
And then the num-- which
I'll call Un.
OK?
So after n collisions, the
big ball velocity is Un.
And it turns out I can
work out what Un is.
Un, after a bit of algebra, Un,
in terms of this initial
velocity, U0 is given
by the following.
It's given by this fairly
simple expression--
I'll tell you what x is in a
minute, so don't panic, Brady.
it's given by--
this bit's kind of irrelevant,
but the bit that's important
is the following.
There's a cosine of
this angle theta.
So x is just the ratio of the
little mass to the big mass.
So it's generally going
to be very small.
You can see that the largest
it's going to be is 1 over 16.
And then it just gets really,
really small very quickly.
So x is generally much
less than unity.
So cos theta is equal to 1
minus x over 1 plus x.
So everything is in terms
of x, this ratio.
So how can I see when this ball
is going to start going
in the opposite direction?
And all I need to do that
is to remember what--
sorry, that's calls
cos n theta--
I missed that one important
n there--
that's cos of n theta,
not cos theta.
All I need to do is look at
this cosine function.
We know what the cosine looks
like from our school days.
Cosine looks like
the following.
It's got, as a function
of some angle, alpha.
The cosine of alpha
looks like this.
It goes between 1 and minus 1.
And it changes when
alpha is pi by 2.
It goes from positive values to
negative values when alpha
is pi by 2.
BRADY HARAN: That's
our smoking gun!
ED COPELAND: There
it is, Brady.
Pis are coming in.
So when n theta or alpha
is less than pi by
2, cosine is positive.
So Un is positive.
That means it's going
in that direction.
But when n theta gets bigger
than pi by 2, cos
n theta goes negative.
So Un goes negative.
And it's beginning to go
in that direction.
So when N is 0, it's the integer
part of 10 to the 0
times pi, which is just pi.
And so the integer part
of that is 3.
When N is 1, the number of
collisions is the integer part
of 10 times pi, which is 31.
And when N is 2, it's the
integer part of 100 times pi,
which is 314.
And this is true for
any value of N.
BRADY HARAN: And the
light went off.
Perfect.